was geht hier ist ein marx und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video wir spiel
minecraft wars zusammen mit - hallo ich
bin heute auch dabei hallo franz sagte
schon am titel gesehen dass wir heute
einen elitären tnt boost probieren dafür
brauchen wir unterschiedlichste dinge
wir brauchen alle mal tätig einmal
drinnen und einmal ein chip medizin
wir brauchen ein schild aus einem ganz
einfachen grund in der 1.9 wurde ja wir
bestimmt ist einiges geupdatet man auch
intensives machen und ein unter anderem
wurde auch der explosion schaden
hochgestellt dann kriegt jetzt
wesentlich mehr schaden durch briefe und
so weiter und so fort wir werden jetzt
ich habe schon delhi drin probieren ein
eliterennen mlg zu machen
das funktioniert so ihr dadurch eine
kult en tk 93 lockte mit einem schild
wichtig mit einem schild und dann fliegt
man ganz oben die luft und macht einen
coolen er in ich würde gerne bei einem
ich habe allerdings nicht so ist das
super equipment man muss ja wie gesagt
relativ gute rüstung haben damit das
funktioniert ich hab wohl die reichel
ein
als host pass auf pass auf pass auf was
du siehst du mich ja aber die sind
gerade straight an ihm vorbeigelaufen
zudem läuft ein partikeln hinterher
die stereotypen hey hallo was geht hier
ab man wir sind so richtig richtige üble
typen halter ok go in die luft jagen
aber in die luft kann ich auch leute ich
werde jetzt meinen cool silicon valley
machen wird hoch gepokert und
und dann aktiviert einfach den e drin
und dann fliegst du mit verdammt viel
stil über die karte und sagte zu mir
gekommen ist auch eine kate schon sehr
schön wirklich sehr romantisch findet ja
jetzt schon sehr schön hält die leute
fallen einfach alle rund man gott ist ja
der absolute wahnsinn schnell schließe
mich weg weil wir mit ihren fans ich
werde mir juristen zusammen mit den tod
das heißt es größter fehler du bastard
versuch so leute letzter zweiter versuch
wir haben schon einige dazwischen gehabt
wir probieren jetzt nochmal beide eliten
zu bekommen das war einfach der absolute
wahnsinn hab echt perfekt die ich
probiere direkt mit uns zu gehen heute
wir wollen nämlich noch mal unbedingt
alle beiden haben zusammen irgendwelche
konstanz macht irgendwelche coole moves
und die gegner anzugreifen weil ich
stelle mir das richtig cool vor wenn
jetzt aber so bald in die luft schießen
mit einem tnt boost und dann das wäre
wahnsinn
okay leute so an rüstung habe ich schon
mal einiges was sich sehen lassen kann
bekommen elitären noch nicht
ich hoffe mal letzte kiste nein leider
keine drin vielleicht besteht noch
hoffnung für uns ansonsten macht franz
jetzt einfach sein ding mit dem heli
drin machst du aufwand machte doch franz
franz immer noch hinter mir
wir sind allerdings eine habe ich
einfach nur für mich
so und ich muss ganz klar ist was
leistet eine unglaubliche verantwortung
auf ihm ein cottbuser angel dir viel
spiele wie meistens überhaupt dann
schild aus blogs dann lässt sich an die
luft schießen absoluter oben ist ein typ
der macht macht ihren pulsschlag den
rother hinter dir
komm schon fans schon bist du hoch genug
nein hier ganz klar es war so knapp habe
nämlich auch noch eine ändert perle
also ich bin nicht mit nicht ganz
unflexibel hatte warnte die who
commissioned lerne ich guckte und lerne
ich könnt ihr einen falschen verdeckten
daher die enten fliegen so komisch ich
habe lieber den geworfen wollte nie drin
holen und sie fliegt einfach irgendwie
so voll strange durch aber der text
nicht
das ist ja noch zittern noch nicht
aufwiegen liegt liegt es und jetzt ist
aber jetzt im baum rtr
doch rca oder waka waka waka waka es hat
ihn hab ihn habe ich hab den büchern gar
nichts wasserfall ex-verein schweden da
ganz hinten
ich sehe nicht sehen so leute eliten
ausgerüstet und es ist richtig das ist
es ist james bond in weinkrämpfe sollte
so das ist eine team die klasse sache
und das nach manchen die kommission
kommt zu dir ist das brennt heute das
brennt zum kommt noch mit denselben gut
mit ihm dies weiter angst leute herum
macht er das
er ist einfach aus gerade okay okay
leute franz ist gerade anscheinend abkam
einsehen das auge ist nicht mehr in
meinen diensten wwe hall ist einfach
ganz tiefer ab mit der die drin so wie
man das halt macht weil die teile sind
echt ok also wir gerade gesehen hat man
kann einfach wie sie aus jeder situation
eigentlich abbauen
die wollen wir allerdings meine
situation jetzt zerstören und mein
wasser wegnehmen das ist natürlich nicht
in meinem interesse so deshalb probiere
ich jetzt mich unauffällig rüber zu
bauen wir probieren jetzt franz grad von
hier unten wieder aufzutauchen muss
quasi aus dem nichts wissen
ich will mich als sicher ich bin halt
abgehauen als brenzlige situation kann
das ab der mangel aber die funktioniert
ihnen locker doch was war das denn
ich bin ich irgendwie an der decke
irgendwo angebaut wo wirst du dich gar
nicht brauche ich nicht einbauen um
einen koffer ist die kreation darf
liegen voll auf kurs die welt wird sich
das heißt weg sind gleich ist es merkt
das problem ist mit elite rennen hast du
halt auch ein nachteil weil du halt ganz
einfach gut
wir kommen noch schicke ich geh jetzt
einfach hier in europa sind auf risiko
ich habe eine neue wasserquelle gesetzt
es ist zwar ein richtig großes holz ist
wasser lawa du und passt auf dass auch
bis auf ok ok denkt reinhard denk
allerdings von den von den fans den 2 es
sind zwei leute mir noch nichts weiter
wasser gesetzt schade leute aber
abgesehen elitärem tnt post sehr streng
sehr nice das kann man leicht gefallen
hat kaufen sie haben leider keine
ungestört zu zweit einen elitären hatten
dass wir für sie gewesen hätte es zum
nicht mal tschüss